I'm if I'm a teenager you're coming back
home to Darkness on a winter cold
Winter's Night yeah I'm livid tonight
afternoon and my dad just passes me the
head torch I slap that on side yeah just
I'll swing at his head
[Music]
right guys as you know back with another
bagger and we head straight into the
juicy wussy question and the question of
the week was if your ex was a dish food
type what would they be and why cool I
think I saw uh was there was there a
thread about this a while ago I S no I
saw I think so I think there was
something that I saw I was like oh
that's a good question it is a good
question I'm intrigued I bet yeah I bet
this came off some disgusting yeah I'm
I'm expecting to hear tribe tribe was
there bye Drive was so common that I'd
even bother putting it yes I put it in
the story I can't rotten bread
we'll see yeah all right said yes an
oatmeal raisin cookie pretended to be
chocolate chip just full of
disappointment
raise and cookies are disgusting bro
oatmeal raisin cookies yeah that's
pretending to be chocolate from afar
from afar they do look like a young
chocolate chip but you're like I want
that wolf in sheep's clothing I want
that you take the first bite you want to
spare all out yeah live it swelled
playing like his chocolate chip full of
disappointment I bet yeah okay cool I
was gonna say 99 of these are gonna be
women in it as a mix there's a mix good
mix it's a good mix I can't even imagine
what demand is that's a good mix a bowl
of jelly
foreign
healthy veg but slime once you eat it
have you ever had that starting
okay when you cut it it's got that
little oh yeah yeah but I should blend
it it's like gooey swear yeah yeah
that's disgusting I've never eaten stuff
like that is that is that African saying
give money that I've never eaten stuff
like that before
would you say when you blend it it's
gooey yeah it's like it's like a draw
stew that's what it's called bro it's
called drugs that's what it's called
it
so you add that because it's not intake
yeah you add that to Stew yeah I didn't
have that with like powder jam and stuff
like that Bang Bros bags bro
you might know what I'm talking about
yeah
yeah yeah
it's fine calm it's facts
mine said Sunday roast popular for no
reason oh popular for no reason swear
Donuts it was always cheat day with her
yeah man I swear yeah
always it's always day with her yeah wow
I wasn't yeah yeah
they thought they thought out with this
one yeah KFC you know it's bad for you
but my God does she taste good
[Applause]
bro what's that uh
what's that nose tune Fried Chicken
I can't remember I can't remember the
bar
uh Fried Chicken Sly Vixen give me heart
disease but always in my kitchen
bro yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
man said a dropped chip should have left
it but ate it anyways
wow yeah man these are these little I
thought that was this is this is this is
dread I'm gonna say it I've got a
brethren
it's a horrible story okay I've got a
bridge in one time yeah oh this is
actually a dread story I hope this
person isn't isn't listening to this
right now yeah it's I'm drama so I had a
veteran one time right this is years ago
and there was a thing that was in love
with him okay in love with him okay and
they must we go I hope we all got a
hotel like a last minute hotel after a
night out because we had nowhere else to
stay so the three of us me him and the
ting
I must have been brushing my teeth
getting ready yeah these men are
clapping cheeks in the other room okay
and I was like swear but I know he
didn't give a damn about this girl okay
he didn't care about it okay okay and um
afterwards she was trying to she was
trying to chat to him about Sutton and
he was just like PNC had set in yeah
immensely
unequivocally immensely he was just
being abusive now he was just being like
downright he was doing downright rude to
this girl
and then she tried to like he must have
said something disparaging about her and
she must have tried to clap back like oh
if I'm so Butters why did you just bang
me and then he says something like you
know when you're out for a meal
and your boy's got a half eaten burger
and says do you want that and you look
at it and think ugh and then you just
drag it anyway
like go on then you're like oh yuck and
you just back it anyway he said that's
you
wow she cried oh I bet bro she I they
were the single bed I had the double she
cried and got in my bed and she just and
she was on the other side of the bed on
top of tilting bawling her eyes out just
like Shake It Fast and he kisses see
from rolled over she was on the other
side of the ball and rise out and I was
like this under the covers wide awake I
didn't know whether to comfort or what
it was the worst night of my life wow I
remember him saying it and I might I was
minding my own business before that
pretended to be asleep yeah yeah I was
pretending to music the whole time and
when he said that I I literally was like
wow
I pretended to wake up I was like wow
wow you didn't just say that bro
and he's got so much ego he was never
going to retract it you could tell he
felt bad yeah he was never attracted to
say she cried her eyes out damn it was
horrible that's horrible it was horrible
wow wow that's horrible yeah that's like
a half eaten Burger
your boy doesn't want anymore
damn you can't think of anything worse
but you back it anyway it says I said
that's you
wow I'm surprised you didn't pack him in
the face
same time
cried that's horrendous but anyway guys
back to it if your ex was a dish what
would they be and why
this thing said Tapas because she's
sharing everything around
Peak the Amanda was scorned in here in
it yeah yeah they are they are they are
they are extra hot Nando's Chicken looks
nice tastes nice but there's a huge red
flag in the middle
I was so surprised risotto so much
potential by disappointing and
underwhelming in every way
okay cool cool cool
oh God oh God [ __ ] when you're pissed
and regretted the next day
this chick said ice cubes he was
cold-hearted but he got me ridiculously
wet bro
yeah she's reminiscent she is geez one
of those frozen spring rolls looks like
they should be tasty but there's just
gross mush inside
damn God yeah this is it's dark this is
yeah yeah you know when
um
you know when like you watch like rap
battles yes you know you want to travel
I was like the one that we watched
something the other day and then like
the first four bars you're like oh yeah
and then they really start going in yeah
yeah and then you can tell that the
opponent is just holding back tears and
you're just like oh yeah
[Laughter]
it's sweet that's hilarious Frozen chips
when they're stuck together because he
has webbed feet
that's not even relevant that's not even
relevant to this you're just looking for
any excuse to outman yeah yeah yeah
flower Bland but somehow they make their
way into everything
that burnt that sticks to the bottom of
the pot because he can burn in the fires
of hell
reverse
[Laughter]
that's just powdered milk because he
lacks substance in every single way
jeez spatchcock chicken because she
couldn't keep her legs closed
it was smart could it keep her legs
closed
the first slice of bread everybody
touches it touches it but nobody wants
it facts that back bread yeah yeah dead
only when it's like hard times it's the
it's the burger drug all over yeah yeah
have you ever tried to like cut it off
yeah I have actually on the hardest days
on the hardest days where I just felt
like I'm obviously a rock bottom yeah
yeah right I can't see the light yeah
yeah so I used to get like the the I
used to like flatten it yeah and try and
do like a horizontal slice okay so it
looks like a normal bit yes worse of
course it just makes it worse because
that's the side of the bread is all yeah
yeah and you're just like what am I
actually doing bro the sandwich is
horrible that was actually really good
yeah they thought that was actually
really really really good I didn't
expect it to be that neither did I but
yeah I'm not gonna lie yeah I saw um
yeah I think our our team is is better
than because I think as you're talking I
think I actually saw it on like a
Instagram post okay and I was looking in
the comments to see I was waiting to see
good stuff dead oh really yeah dead just
dead they're just talking about sardines
probably there was loads of stuff like
that but yeah again a lot of them had no
contact so I just picked out the juicy
ones yeah they were banging they did
well awesome guys all right so welcome
back
thank you for joining us on this
luscious Monday it's episode
243 with your boys J Money Fire Lord
fake shifts and gigs we are still here
for some reason
um but yeah welcome back man obviously
if you want to be a real cult baby
you might be your first time with us and
you're thinking what's it called people
called baby yeah you you might
understand that your boys here have a
certain law a certain charm that only a
cult Leaguer might might have you know
what I mean
um so we actually do have a cult and
it's over on patreon so if you want to
join
it's not free it's definitely not free
but it's definitely not a pyramid scheme
yeah yeah yeah the barrier to entry is
low it's only going to cost you three
pound a month run the pizza sng guys and
when you're over there whilst you're
waiting for the Log Cabin to be
constructed you can digest three years
three plus years I think now of content
that we've produced over there it's
uncensored it's very little edited it's
very raw it gets deep it's a good time
and on top of that guys you get to join
our insanely popular Discord Channel
where all the other cult babies talk
about all the [ __ ] that they want to do
facts all the [ __ ] that they've been
doing I see selfies in there I see
interesting discussions in there a
couple arguments yeah but I guess it
gets resolved that's how we do it like a
family it's a pink family over there
guys so head on over patreon.com shits
and gigs also guys if you are watching
us on YouTube you might be thinking
these guys are collating Subs
yeah a couple of months ago was 200k yep
the month after that it was 300K the
month of the s400k literally doesn't
make any sense crazy so guys make sure
you are part of that gang subscribe
right now put the notification Bell on
and make sure you are ready for every
episode that we drop as of when we drop
it and finally guys if you're listening
on any of the podcast apps please leave
us a nice review five stars is obviously
preferable but whatever you say say it
with chest
um and without any further ado
my tight hamstring honey over here Fire
Lord flakes is gonna educate us with
some fun facts of the day hilarious
let's go
see as we all know uh the World Cup is
drawing to a close
I'm about to talk to your man about the
first initial World Cup that happened in
1930. oh we're doing a little Deep dive
team a little history lesson all right
hang on let me actually
pattern up and face you like a man say
less
I love stuff like this so the World Cup
in 1930 was held in Uruguay and to reach
there why okay sorry carry on it's just
the first time sorry sorry it's just
where FIFA said it was held and to reach
there the European teams traveled
together on a single ship they traveled
across the Atlantic yeah bro yeah bro
it's a different time all of Europe yeah
the European team traveled together on a
single ship they traveled across the
Atlantic and picked up the Brazilian
players from Rio
players used to train on a top deck
um
Joe's Joe's room I think I'm assuming is
a player traveled on a ship with the
World Cup in his suitcase
in his suitcase wow
that's that's wild that's actually wild
all the associated also all the
associate teams were invited to play as
um the only tournament without
qualifying process but most of the
countries rejected the invitation
because of the distance
Argentina were the bad boys of the World
Cup as their match was the most on-field
violence had the most unfield violence
sorry police were called to control a
violent scrap in their 6-1 win over
Chile by the semifinals against USA it
escalated
a taco left a USA play with a broken leg
and a mass brought a mass brawl broke
out
an Argentinian player operated four
teeth of an American while another ended
up in hospital within with an injured
stomach
Jesus bro in a match the USA manager
ranted a referee to confront him as the
decision went against the USA whilst he
sprinted he tripped and a chloroform
bottle in his pocket got smashed a what
a chloroform bottle got smashed
the manager was left unconscious by the
fumes it had to be treated straight away
wow what is this bro chaos this is the
1930s that's what this is 15 000
Argentine supporters settled from their
Coast to watch the final but um but on
their way to but on their way to the
ship
sorry but on their way the ship got lost
due to heavy fog and they reached Monte
video I think that's how you pronounce
it a day after the final upon hearing
that Argentina lost the final they
started riots in Uruguay also the the
Bulls back in the day used to be heavy
and the at in the World Cup the Bolivian
players used to wear barrettes as well
as they played
there was also a premature funeral a
Romanian player fell in a Romanian
player fell ill during the trip back
home
he was taken to hospital in Italy's
Genoa when a boat stopped with while the
team left the country after the team's
arrival in Romania news erupted that the
guy had passed away even his mother was
convinced and made a funeral arrangement
for his departed son but he came back
into full health and his mother fainted
on the spot
fan this is all nuts this is all nuts
yeah
blood clots this sounds pointless bro
the whole whole thing sounds relevant
and pointless the whole world cup was
they're just doing that hooligan doing
up hooliganism do you know chloroform do
not fake deaths doing up wearing Berets
during the match yeah referees doing
upper Madness didn't exist kind of bro
they were we wore suits really yeah the
referees were like Suit and Tie
I remember in like a level sport or
something like that you'd learn about
like the origins of sport and it used to
be was it like mob football they used to
call us as just beef it was just beef
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
what it was like this beef that's that's
how they got their aggression I think
that's what they did that's all they did
I bet Africa went invited because black
people don't like to fight like I think
one night in fact because I don't think
there were African teams at World Cup
back then no because these men are just
scrapping that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah I think well I'll say I think I
have no idea when the first time this is
pre pre-World War
[Music]
it was nuts all on the ship
every single European team so yeah you
have to go over there
smack this man up and then get on the
same boat home yeah yeah yeah yeah I
promise you I'm poking holes in the in
the deck we're all going down okay I'm
not going back to my country with this
this kind of [ __ ] okay that's
interesting man that's very interesting
how you finding the World Cup so far um
very good very entertaining obviously a
lot of um surprise wins or surprise
losses I should say
um but yeah it's it's going it's going
really well why what's what are you
gonna say no I wasn't gonna say anything
going oh I was gonna ask you who do you
think out of the final
what four eight teams well by the time
this comes out four teams who do you
think is going to win
so who so who's in at the moment there's
France there's Brazil France Brazil
England England Argentina Argentina uh
Morocco Morocco
and Croatia I believe
I feel like there's more Brazil I said
Brazil Netherlands say Croatia no no I'm
saying I think oh you think Brazil
I think so
um I think England are about to get
nervous that's what typically happens
the stage is a bit
we're just not yeah we're not we're just
not clutch I think if you talk about
England in any sporting scenario ever
clutch never really like you know yeah I
think the last time we were even in that
realm was probably Johnny Wilkinson in
the Rugby World Cup like 600 years ago
okay when he did that one kick yeah
that's one that's our claim that's our
claim to clutch okay it's not been
clutched since okay not not when the
snakes are high yeah we have to Fumble
okay we have to vote and that's when the
racism starts yeah of course of course
it gets that's when we're pointing
fingers this stuff we'll Point your
fingers I remember
I remember when I was PT and I used to
PT this lovely lady
lovely lady and uh I can't even remember
her name to be honest and we're talking
about after the euros and she come in
and then um she was like I don't
understand all this like
all this kneeling all these armbands all
this extra stuff like why do we have to
draw so much attention to like racism
and stuff like that like I feel like
it's worse if you if you just draw an
attention to it that's why it happens
worse and I was like I don't think
that's the case I'm not gonna lie to you
I'm just not sure that's the case and
she was like yeah because everyone was
like kicking off about like the the boys
missing the penalties and all that stuff
and she was like I'm not gonna lie to
you
I did notice they were black yeah and I
was like what that's what she said she
said
she said I'm not black yes I did right
I'm not gonna lie to you I did notice
they were black and I was like what do
you not understand that's the problem
yeah yes this is the awareness that
we're talking about so why so what
everyone knows they were black they're
human beings you can see they're black
bro what are we talking about I know
it's that black man can't take a penny
to save their life I just noticed it and
I'm not racist this is just this is the
observations you might have given me oh
you can't do penalties oh my God it was
wild bro so yeah this is what's gonna
happen England yeah yeah England will
fail to become clutch
soccer will trip on Saturn yeah and then
the whole yeah the whole jungle will
crumble and we'll we'll go into it again
for another two years before he has a
chance to redeem himself I hope the
thing is I'm like that's very plausible
but I also hope it doesn't happen yeah
of course um desperately hoping that
doesn't happen yeah it can't run again
after the Euros that was that was nuts
bro the whole Fiasco was nuts but yeah
let's not even dive into that yeah
does it matter
he's doing up world
hunger didn't matter yeah it didn't kick
the ball that's what they said kick the
ball in the net stop getting medals and
kick the ball stop feeding our kids stop
feeding our kids we'll feed them
ourselves
yeah don't tell me how to pair it kick
the ball kick the ball yeah bring home
Glory that's all your work yeah talk
about school dinners
um but cool right I've actually got an
am I the [ __ ] oh gang this one's
weird bro it's a I'm just gonna warn you
we're just gonna preempt it we'll
discuss what we want to discuss it's
open and sharp okay it's factually open
and shut from the first sentence okay
it's open and shut okay
right I want to know if I'm the [ __ ]
for banging This Woman's husband
[Music]
right she threw it way back in 2019 say
less bro in 2019 this woman went on
Facebook and harassed me and my mum
random harass me and my mum accusing me
of banging her husband and being and
being his prostitute wow bro as an
accusation wow you've been bagging my
husband and you're his prostitute his
prostitute
personal here's prostitute oh wow yeah
yeah
um right
she claimed he paid for my college
tuition my phone and that he'd taken me
out for Valentine's Day my then
boyfriend who I was living with had paid
for for said College my phone and him my
mum and I had went to a concert on
Valentine's Day
now let's just be clear her husband was
obsessed with me
but I did not pass him the poem
we didn't even live in the same country
this is this is where the information
falls apart we didn't even live in the
same country now in 2022 I have my own
apartment I'm single and I'm still
low-key traumatized about this Facebook
situation
he's offered to come and visit me and
being the spiteful [ __ ] that I am I
told him yes
and I banged him because why not
he's just he's still obsessed and pays
my rent and utilities
man them need to stop doing that
he's still obsessed and pays my rent and
utilities that's I just want to know if
I'm the [ __ ] for doing what she said
that I did years before
yes sir yes open literally yeah
why do you why do women sometimes feel
like their needs to justify their
actions yeah like they're trying to
justify the actions that they know is
bad anyway bro and the thing is as well
she said listen to me she said I'm
traumatized that three years ago this
woman dm'd me and said I'm her husband's
prostitute fast forward he pays my rent
and utilities and I banged him because
why not
there's a couple loopholes in there but
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you are like what what are we discussing
here what are we discussing here you are
yeah it's mad bro that's mad and this
spray is nuts
spreads actually nuts is he still
married he he must be yeah he must be he
pays my rent and utilities funniest
sentence I've ever heard London near to
wiser yes I don't know why man are doing
that
what's all of that about what's all of
that about I don't know I can't do that
you literally can't you can't do that
man then we can't do that stop yeah stop
um I said interesting one as well maybe
I might be way off kilter but I think
it's actually like a massive
culture because um so basically this
person said this on in on patreon okay
and I can't see any other information
about this person apart from the
currency that they pay in okay and they
pay in American dollars okay so I'm
assuming she's American okay and I think
there's a big culture after speaking to
some people I think there's a massive
culture shift from the UK to the US in
terms of how this this thing runs this
rent and utilities team and how it runs
car rent phone nails hair everything
managers yeah yeah as you spending
they're used to that yeah and it's just
so second nature that like you can have
an argument like I could be an American
guy have an argument with my girl
and then as a makeup thing should be
like cash at me this
it's that's fair that's fine cash at me
this yeah and I'm like yeah Daddy pay
this quick
and you know as long as I clicking yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah quick quick whereas
in UK man can have money I promise you
now no chicken tell me yeah no chickens
you could never beef me yeah
beef me I mean black come off my phone
come off my phone
and I get a text
with a local PayPal request Paypal
invoice and said if you want to make up
daddy send me this daddy send me this
I'm blocking you yeah I will send you
the the most heinous voice note the
block you say yeah blocking so can't
respond you can dwell in that yeah
forming a voicemail and I want to see
you come online time four minutes so I
know that you've just about finished it
and then blocked it in your block
who do you think you're talking to
that's wild yeah yeah Americans are
mandam stop yeah literally literally
stop it can't run it literally can't run
because these are getting away with
that's expensive regardless of where you
live yes expensive yeah and the fact
that she's allowing man to pay obviously
you would but like he's been paying
renting utilities and as far as We Know
that's not even the subject matter yeah
a subject matter is that she he said can
I come see you and she said yes because
uh because of on a Revenge thing for
think about this he hit her up I said
babes I want to come see you in her head
she's thinking Revenge thing gang he can
come around I'm going to sleep with him
this whole time he's already paying
renting utilities yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah facts and he still has to
request can I come see you yeah the
renting utilities just standard just is
that's just the barrier to entry yeah
that's the transaction yeah if you want
to chat to me yeah you've got to pay my
bills rent and utilities need to be
covered and then I'll decide if I want
to see you and the only reason I'm
actually seeing you is to spite your
wife it's not because you're paying for
my lifestyle because she accused me yeah
she falsely accused me of being your
your take your personal prostitute yeah
yeah yes and I'm living about it so now
I will be so three years later I'm going
to take the opportunity yeah and make
her make her writers obsessed with me
damn that's a disease that's a disease
yeah these men have lost the plot yeah
that's some Destiny's Child bills will
build stuff that's mad fellas what is
good this episode is brought to you by
our favorite producers of ball trimmers
these are manscapes these guys are the
global leaders in below the waist
grooming and we're leaving 2022 with a
clear mind and clean Bulls Brothers I'm
asking it was to help you do this with a
special offer all you need to do is use
the code sng Sierra November gold know
what it is and that's going to give you
20 off and free shipping worldwide at
manscaped.com take the leap into the new
year and join seven million men that's
14 million balls that bro when we
started doing these reads I'm pretty
sure it was two million yeah yeah
there's back I don't think it's a
coincidence that it's now seven but here
we go seven million men all the cult
babies trust manscaped John Pon code is
sng masgate.com let's get back to the
episode boom bye bro yeah
anyway anyway I can't even yeah that is
literally open and sharp that's
literally
easy well I've got a trash news for you
Peng go
so I don't think you might have seen
this already dad makes family wear head
torches and only turns on heating once a
week
no I haven't but
but I mean tree you sounded like you
were going yeah I was gonna say no no
but I was putting to be fair I was gonna
say no I haven't but I'm putting my dad
out on okay and it's like for probably
fast because if there's bear use in
there and the thermostat just clicking
livid all right say less as the cost of
living crisis continues to affect
millions of people every day
chavda 53 has gone to Extreme Measures
in attempt to try and save as much money
as possible after seeing that bill more
than doubling price to 320 pounds a
month swear that knew he and his family
had to cut back on the energy usage he
has gone to he has gone the extra step
to ensure his family is saving as much
money as possible following the
expensive bills the debt has introduced
a no electricity at home policy where
the family wear head torches around the
house instead of turning on the lights
in the dark alongside that the family is
also limiting their heating by only
turning it on once a week and are
keeping themselves warm by wrapping up
in coats and blankets
chavda's wife Moda and their children 14
year old and 20 year old are making a
mammoth I'm making a mammoth effort in
attempt to lower their annual bill of 3
800 pounds
Prada a man said we've got a no
electricity at home policy isn't that
what um what's that meat with that meat
brother
um liver King is that what you said he
does oh yeah oh no that's at night
that's like only at night that's at
night yeah yeah man said no electricity
at home so where are we where are we
doing electricity that's Bonkers you
must have a
he must have a um those portable gas
cookers and stuff oh yeah a little hot
place yeah yeah yeah must have one of
them no I'm not doing up Refugee in my
own home brother I promise you I'm not
doing that Refugee in my own home I'm if
I'm a teenager yeah come back home to
Darkness on a winter cold Winter's Night
yeah I'm livid midnight afternoon and my
dad just passes me the head torch I slap
that on side yeah just I'll swing at his
head I'm living I'm kissing my teeth I'm
going to my boys yeah and I'm desperate
is it's a it's depressing because I'm
desperate to go to school
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bro I couldn't
I couldn't face that I literally
couldn't face that I remember when I was
a kid even till now my mom was stingy
with the heating stingy with the heat
and stingy with fans
so big winner and Peak summer we're
suffering in my yard I've got a fan
story yeah I remember till this day I
remember
I remember as a as a teenager as a kid
growing up all the time it'll be
freezing in my yard yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] freezing in my yard through hand
and my toes will be blue and I'm like
Mom please please yeah I'm freezing
inside and the audacity she would turn
to me and be like bro you're wearing a
t-shirt put some clothes on put a jumper
right I'm in my house I'm in a [ __ ]
House customer changes in England yes
this is the Queen's lamp bro yeah yeah
yeah we we used to run this and look
where we are I'm in my house wearing
three pairs of socks mom please he toss
heat us up it was the worst yeah my mom
will sit there till now blanket oh my
God so she refuses to touch the heating
it's the most infuriating experience we
had these days now in my yard I'll put
the heating on 27 and just open the
windows
I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not open the windows
bro that's hilarious you're trying to
happen on Happy Meal the other day I
swear so God
someone would have bet my yard down if
they knew what I was doing nothing I was
destroying the atmosphere the other day
I had to Radiator on full blast yeah
oh this is horrible at the radiator in
full blast the window open and the fan
on
nah that's a piss take tram I've lived
through stuff and I'm gonna live the way
I Wanna Live
I don't care I'm a grown up
I'm literally a grown I pay my own bills
I pay the bills in here I pay the bills
in this house and I'll put on wherever I
want to put on I have both windows open
fan was blaring oh my this that's wild
brother radiator was boiling you know
when it clicks yeah yeah when the metal
starts to click yeah
yeah I remember and this was back in
Crystal Palace me and my sister uh we
shared a room still at that time and it
was summer I remember some holidays and
it was also one of them times where
obviously it goes darker probably
between nine and ten but parents still
set you to bed early they still saying
it's a bit while the Sun is up and the
kids are still playing kids are still
playing
too much energy I can't sleep the sun's
up Mom the Sun's Up and you're telling
me to go to bed anyway moving on there's
sick of the sight of you bro yeah so I'm
I'm probably in like boxes or shorts or
whatever and the top
my scissors didn't happen I'm in my bed
and it's boiling the windows are doing
like windows are fully open yeah there's
no breeze it's not doing anything I was
like Mom we need a fan we need sign we
need science because it's warm in here
yeah yeah it's warming it she's like all
right bear she brings in a fan but what
she does is she faces the fan the other
way it's one of them Rotator fans but
faces it away from us and I'm thinking
why are you doing that she said she
doesn't want the room to get too cold so
you might get I can't think this is my
aircon it's not air conditioning it's a
fan this is room temperature and
temperature cycled air big man face it
towards me
but it's one of the ones where I only
thought about it after the fact because
as soon as I saw the fact I just went
straight back to bed I thought about I
was so livid
I was so livid bro that's hilarious
playing and I'm struggling for air in my
bedroom
I'm struggling for Breeze I couldn't
believe it
I couldn't believe it
my science Hall and I was thinking is it
because zainab's in here as well that
it's getting a bit more stuffy I was
thinking if I go to baby to the other
room bro I was thinking of All Sorts I
was thinking of All Sorts bro I was
living same times me my dad put us on
Thief time when the sun was blaring this
is when I was a you yeah the sun was
blaring and we lived in the chavviest
area okay at my dad my dad this is the
first house my dad got after he left my
mum okay
so busted area where the parents don't
care what their kids do okay they don't
care what it is yeah yeah come seven
eight o'clock Sunset everyone's playing
outside these men are still doing up
water guns and I'm in bed and me and my
brother used to have to share a double
bed oh my God so bro in the summer yeah
the curtains were closed me and my
brother are laying in bed there's no TV
in there hey I'm just hearing bear noise
rollerblades fun fun and activities
that's all I'm hearing outside and
there's things out there I can hear
things out there there's things in jean
shorts out there I'm livid I'm like
eight or nine and I'm just about getting
sussing it there's things out there
things in jean shorts
from things in jean shorts are that fake
green hair stuff they used to plait in
their hair yeah yeah yeah spirograph
looking thing yeah yeah I remember I was
vexed and they said Dad please yeah
please let's go let's go out bro and
he'd say you might need it he would it
would shut down immediately yeah but you
might need a routine you need a routine
I said that is Saturday
it's Saturday 8pm what you mean bro
let's listen let me list the weekend
bring a DVD player into your side yeah
sign is it closer closer for no reason
because the sun isn't doing up
like shine yeah just shine on all the
reflection of everything let's close the
Blazers no TV fan close the planes he
said you need a routine and I'm hot
there was no fan in there either I
remember I've had to share a double bed
me and my brother would fight
that he would get a best of us a good
[ __ ] fight get the best of us
bro we would fight because I'd be hot
I'd be hot but I need a blanket yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was in between my legs
I got one leg out yeah and I have to
roll it over and my brother's yanking it
back and I'm yanking it back yeah and I
don't even wanting the cover
so then it will be back and forth back
and forth until I'm kicking up a fuss
and I'll say well I've touched this
blanket one more time bro touch his back
one more time and I'm sweating and I'm
still hearing laughter outside and I'm
so many stimuluses I'm not even not
enough for boxes so I'm just in pants
I've got a hairless physique and I'm in
advance
I'm screwing bro hello
pants hilarious bro I've got one all
over and headless was eating on my pants
and I'm passing my brother touch this
blanket one more time bro is it gonna be
the last night you have
and it was back when you couldn't put
pause on your brother's face yeah okay
okay because it couldn't be marked yeah
yeah so we used to punch each other in
the chest we used to aren't you Jennifer
in a chest I hated it I hated it it
didn't go too much and then my dad would
just say behave yeah was there anything
else behave and he wouldn't even come in
he just said from outside yeah yeah and
he's just kissing your teeth
worst Summers of my life oh worse every
week every Saturday
for a whole summer it was the it was the
worst thing bro all I had to look
forward to was swimming and wimpy in the
morning
and maybe a trip to Blockbusters if we
were lucky yeah yeah for your brother to
get the same DVDs to get never-ending
story every week
oh that sounded like hell yeah yeah yeah
yeah hilarious it was it was hilarious
absolute hell but yeah whatever my man's
doing that needs to stop oh facts facts
yeah yeah yeah this price thing I'll go
broke I don't care walking hands the
[ __ ] the headset the headlamp the
headlamp to your you yeah use that nah
use that for the rest of the day not in
Western Society I promise you you
couldn't raise me in this country and
treat me like that I'm accustomed to
certain lifestyle
you can't raise me here for a better
quote unquote better life and then then
put me through that I'd go to school
pale my teachers would be asking me
questions what's going on at home what's
going on at home because you look
different every time yeah you're not
getting vitamins bro bro I'm not getting
sunk yeah you're not getting nutrients
of him is nothing oh my God yeah that's
that's wild that's funny right you got a
thread for us no uh yeah I do have a
thread actually
you bought a Phantom for that against
the wall bro so he was oscillating the
wrong way I was livid
she was like I don't want you man to
catch a cold
yeah at the time I couldn't comprehend
yeah I couldn't comprehend what I was
hearing at the time
so I'm thinking she's probably right
yeah she's probably right yeah she's
looking out for me looking out for me if
I'm I was boiling and I didn't get up to
turn it around I don't know why I
remember bro
I used to need stuff like this is them
early nights has reminded me I used to
my mom used when I was a you yeah used
to have a tape cassette
and do you remember Pingu yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a
little trumpet map we had a tape
cassette of Pingu okay and she used to
run that at bedtime okay my brother had
bunk beds but we were forbidden for
resetting it once it once it finished
and once the episode finishes
yeah yeah yeah yeah there was no
situation because it was double-sided
okay so the little tape cassette yeah
you'll pop it out take it out yeah flip
it yeah yeah episode two yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I was up in there like five years old I
remember the thing when the tape
cassette runs out you can hear it go
like
because all the tapes are running around
and I used to sneak out a bit and I had
the creakiest flipping bunk bed bro oh
you're on top of them I was on top okay
and I don't know what it was my mum was
such a Nazi with this Pingu tape bro if
she heard you creeping out to reset
these things you're busting you're gonna
smack you to pieces
she wasn't having it bro wow yeah I'm
just having all these these recalls of
just like Dreadful nights as a kid
Dreadful night I just wanted to do a
Pingu bro yeah I just wanted to see what
he was doing next week and she was
having none of it she was sprinting and
smack you up oh my goodness it was worth
it though because if you could if you
could patent it and you can get back in
bed and you'll just hear in episode two
yes it was a cast it was worth taking
the risk kids are willing to risk
anything factual
anything they are for whatever they want
they are yeah yeah but yeah um thread
fellas when did when you try to leave
that woman how did it go I'm trying to
see son oh say less okay cool cool she
pulled a knife out and I had to get out
of her hand straight away
never she pulled a knife out brother
that sounds like home girl this was all
based on uh what's her face uh uh
Hospital
Christians
as soon as you said it sounds like Mike
I was thinking of frustrated yeah she's
crazy She's Dangerous
she told my man you're not leaving me
leaving and he just looks like the
camera like help me yeah right yeah
scary stuff
we split she moved out a few months
later lived with her mum for two years
we're married now
oh
no man just fell back into the same trap
the same trap
she put sugar in both of our gas tanks
and came back to wake me up and tell me
I ain't going nowhere
so I had my car towed to the shop and
heard coat and hers towed to her mum's
house where she ended up enough that I
changed the locks wow both of the things
she said we're not going nowhere your
car's not leaving a neva's mind we're
stuck
love me
yeah wow okay I looked her in her eyes
and said we're toxic for each other and
we need to stop this she replied with a
simple no and this was back in 2011 when
toxic wasn't even a thing oh raw she
just said no
she wrap
she wrapped her entire body around my
leg I would have let go I still have a
picture on my phone till this day
bro I had one experience one time with
an ex that I was living with yeah
and I am
I stayed out she had had she would she
had it up to here with me okay she had
it up to here with my Antics yeah and it
came in one morning yeah I stayed out
the night before I came in one morning
my suitcase was packed
my suitcase was packed on the stairs no
fam and she was bluffing me okay because
I said swear okay is this my suitcase
yeah I said gang I picked up and watch
out then she grabbed it she grabbed it
so what are you doing but I was like I'm
leaving bro I'm taking a suitcase you
packed and I'm leaving she said the only
reason I packed it because I knew you
wanted to leave me she unzipped the
thing and drapes her clothes out
it was the most gaslighting situation of
ever experienced I knew you wanted to
leave me as I packed it for you and she
said nah and she said stop stop stop
just crying for that she was crying
Drake all the clothes out nah that's not
leaving that's correct oh that's correct
I'm dragging my suitcase keep the
clothes on the floor I'm dragging my
suitcase out the yard that's crazy talk
that's crazy talk oh bro it was mad but
I I hate living with my mom so much I
was willing to part with anything
I didn't even hate living with it it was
like it was the thought of turning up
and knocking onto my mom's door yeah
yeah I was just like whatever yeah you
know what I mean whatever like we'll
work something out that's jokes
all right back to it uh she cried and
begged on her knees for me to stay for a
good 20 minutes and an hour later she
was on Twitter calling me all types of
problems
are broke
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
she begged for 20 minutes
and now she's going to be broke on
Twitter
yeah if the Street's really new what
happened yeah oh that's hilarious
as I said we were outside her best
friend's house getting domestic
getting domestics
she spam called my mom's she's spam
called my mom 60 times then pulled up to
her crib my sister beat her ass [ __ ]
her again a few years later a few days
later sorry I haven't seen her since
West that's very West West that's that's
unnecessary yeah yeah I couldn't think
of the word but it's unnecessary
completely unnecessary what's the point
in all of that you're trying to leave
the last time I left the woman she tried
to take my life and my freedom
fam wow this chick beat up my sneaky
link and stabbed one of my tires then
cried on my voicemail for an hour
well people people do the most in this
situation guys do the most as well I
would love to see the guy version yeah
I'll say him like
I know in many situations like
you can't tell you can't even say what
went down because he's not free anymore
yeah yeah he's not on road anymore
she had a seizure and her aunt called me
from the hospital to say she was in a
coma
that's impossible
that's actually impossible because I
said I'm leaving this I don't want to do
this anymore
you started shaking
she just started shaking
I said and just oxygen just wouldn't
make it past the blood-brain barrier and
she just would have said she's in a coma
come now first of all why is the only
calling me fine
where's the parents yeah situation
where's her parents yeah speak to her
parents because I'm not her next of kin
I'm not her next of kin
I tell you that for free
that's a West Chat
oh
she sent me two four minute plus voice
notes and I told her I'm not listening
to that [ __ ] oh bro
they can't stand
I'm not listening to that [ __ ] oh she
would have been living oh one million
see that
man said I got ropes back in for us for
seven more months
of course ah
roped back in
stress bro the most stress stress I got
roped back in one time I got caught
stepping out oh sorry I got caught
stepping now yeah but I kind of didn't
want to do it anyway yeah yeah yeah the
relationship thing
and then she beefed me about it and you
know what I'm like tears yeah obviously
we're together we're crying we're back
together obviously uh she was just like
I don't see why you would do this or
this or not and I was like I'm just a
bad guy
that's what I said I was like I'm just a
bad guy
briefly and you just you deserve better
yeah and she was like
so like
so what are you gonna do it again and
obviously me feeling bad I was like well
no of course not but like we're done
anyway so like you're breaking up with
me so yeah it doesn't matter yeah it
literally doesn't matter and she was
like well no I never said I was breaking
up with you and I was like Lord God
myself don't do this and I'm like I
can't cheat on her
then her take me back for me to dump her
yes that's impossible because I don't
know what's gonna happen
she's gonna yeah she's gonna do up arson
for sure that's impossible bro that
can't in front yeah I had to explode
yeah yeah I literally I had to affirm it
I had to firm it and tell her I promise
I won't do it again
and what was him for months I was
probably in for over a year after that
I'm not even playing with you oh my God
I'm not even playing with you oh my God
you had your foot out the door Jack yeah
I literally had my foot out the door and
I thought there's no way I can cheat on
her be forgiven and then break up with
her in the same conversation
alive
she would die so yeah I think you think
it went on for like another year yeah
that's probably what could Sean rock is
on yeah yeah until one dad had enough
yeah and I just texted her I said are
you happy she said yes I don't know and
that was the end of it
yeah I'm not are you happy yeah are you
no no done safe
oh my God
she bet fam she begged me to stay just
to break up with me
facts ego ego ego ego
one girl threatened to get me killed and
one facetimed me with a bottle of pills
saying she down if I don't get back with
her
that's not funny but
prized Almighty that's tap yeah yeah
that's tapped
I changed my number on her and she came
up to my she came up to my job just to
get my new number I was working two jobs
and I don't know how she found out which
one I was at I usually worked overnight
that on this job but I was there in the
morning shift that day oh wow find me
wow how did you find me yeah she's
putting trackers in the car last but not
least
threatened to shoot me and Chase me in
her car through traffic
[Music]
all because I said I wanted to leave bro
chased me in a car through traffic fam I
dumped a girl one time
I've got so many stories about this why
is this thread resonate so much
um items to go one time uh
over Facebook message okay because she
was on it like any girl so this is when
we're at Uni any girl who from our uni
who would follow me would get DM from my
girlfriend add me as a friend if I
accept it as a friend DM is that that my
girlfriend's DM who are you who are you
to my man that's what that she was doing
that on a daily and I was like this
can't run so there was someone uh at our
uni yeah
who was it it was um
raw I've forgotten her name now it
doesn't matter I think I'm the chick
that gave you CDs or something like that
oh no no okay okay not her okay okay
she was one of the corporations yeah
yeah okay no no no this was um our
Brethren
um
uh Tulsi nah aubergine uh light-skinned
blue eyes call me no
um donation
it's our Niche is brethrenicious
um
um
curly hair yes I know exactly you're
talking about Capri
come on Capri must have added me on on
Facebook I was like gang yeah accepted
yeah yeah
and I was with my boy he sat next to me
and um
saw because he used to have the
messenger thing here and it was the
green lights if they're online I saw my
girlfriend was online and I said if she
messages me about this thing I promise
you I'm dumping her yeah
I clicked it we were sat here and my
mom's I remember in my mom's living room
I clicked accept yeah
within seconds
who the hell is that
I was like a suppression from you need
to chill she's like swear swear I'm
messaging her
fam I said don't bother I'm done it's a
wrap yeah fam we had an argument over
here we had an argument over here yeah
that night a cousin I've never heard of
was giving me threats
I cousin I never heard of was
threatening yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember he had a baby blue
tracksuit in his D in his baby blue
Sweden with the hood up yeah and he's
flipping uh profile his profile pic and
he was like if you ever do this to my
cousin again or something like that I'm
sending a few yeah yeah
who is his brush he said you should have
thought about that before you was moving
this way
she said you're going to get what you
deserve wow
no she never said that you gotta get
what you deserve
scorned I said for no reason because I'm
unhappy because I'm unhappy in this
relationship you're going to get what
you deserve that's a scary bar to say to
someone I was I was um I was playing it
cool but I was terrified wow I was
playing it cool but I was terrified she
all she saw was red oh facts you're
gonna get what you deserved she messaged
the cousin that she never speaks to yeah
who she thought was the most dangerous
yeah I said message him yeah and what
kind of fool does it it's like yeah
right my female cousin could never
message me and said my boyfriend just
dumped me message him and say what
you're just threaten him no not your
business how to do your own stuff it was
mad he was mad hilarious right done yeah
that's a thread done paying all right
guys well thank you so much for today
and this was a little a cheeky fun one
uh as always catch us on Thursday
patreon.com shits and gigs uh and until
then
[Music]
thank you